Why do so many of the indigenous cultures
of the colder regions of North America seem
to share the same legend?
A legend that tells of a monster that lurks
in the forests, bringing cold and death to
any that meet it.
This creature is an omen of famine, a territorial
beast that preys on human beings.
Some cultures describe it as an unholy abomination,
a spirit of winter and a warning against the
dangers of selfishness, one that is created
whenever a person resorts to cannibalism in
order to survive.
It will gladly devour any man, woman or child
that wanders into its territory, holding a
horrifying and insatiable hunger for human
flesh.
So how did so many cultures end up with the
same story?
Could it be because… it’s real?
Depictions of the beast vary, but it is most
commonly recognized by its tall, skeletal
form, like a body exhumed from the grave,
even carrying the stench of death and decay
with it.
Anyone who encounters one risks being eaten
or transformed into a creature just like.
The monster’s name means an ‘evil spirit
that devours mankind’ though to even say
the name is taboo, as it’s believed to give
power to the beast.
Of course, these are all just legends, right?
Stories to warn against the dangers of greed
and selfishness, but otherwise nothing to
fear.
There’s no proof that such a beast could
actually be roaming the frozen wastes?
Many at the SCP Foundation felt the same way,
until they heard about SCP-323, the Wendigo’s
Skull.
Kept under lock and key by the Foundation
with around the clock surveillance, SCP-323
is an anomalous object with ties to the various
Wendigo legends.
As the object’s moniker suggests, SCP-323
is a skull; not a human skull, mind you, it
more closely resembles a cervid skull.
Cervids are a family of mammals that include
most varieties of deer, elk, and other similar
animals, and this particular cervid skull
sports a tall pair of antlers.
SCP-323 is definitely not a fresh skull either.
It shows signs of weathering and a few scars
across the surface, looking as if the bone
has been bleached and eroded through exposure
to the elements.
The skull is also missing its lower jaw, and
has a sizable hole on the rear underside that
may have been carved using stone tools.
SCP-323 is kept restrained inside an armored
container within a concrete containment cell,
and personnel are only ever allowed near it
to check the restraints for signs of damage.
Additionally, any Foundation staff that enter
SCP-323’s cell must be accompanied by an
armed security officer, and in the event of
a containment breach the entire site is to
be evacuated.
Seems like a lot of precautions and safety
measures for an old piece of bone.
Surely a harmless deer skull could never be
that dangerous, right?
Wrong.
You might be forgiven for thinking that a
skull can’t possibly cause harm.
After all, SCP-323 is just a skull, then whatever
animal it belonged to is dead.
But this skull is far more than it appears
to be.
Through extensive testing, the SCP Foundation’s
researchers have learned that the skull…
isn’t dead.
No, this skull is awake and aware.
It can see, hear and has a sense of touch,
and it can and will react to various stimuli.
However, this does not necessarily mean that
SCP-323 is alive or even sentient, but it
definitely appears to have some level of sapience.
It will target certain members of personnel
that get too close and has attempted multiple
times to breach containment.
It also reacts violently to anyone speaking
English or French near it, the only two languages
prohibited inside SCP-323’s cell.
So, while the skull is not technically alive,
it is definitely aware.
Still, why the need for so many protocols
to keep it contained?
It’s not as if a skull can just walk off
on its own.
Of course not, but SCP-323 can move, at least
to a certain degree.
Often in a reactionary manner, SCP-323 will
vibrate or move on its own.
For example, turning to watch as personnel
enter its containment cell.
In most cases, these movements are tiny and
insignificant.
But other times, the skull lunges, launching
itself at Foundation personnel as it desperately
tries to get free.
Now you know why it’s kept restrained.
So, we have an antlered cervid skull that
can move and has a low level of awareness,
on their own these would be more than enough
to warrant the Foundation’s interest, but
the anomalous properties of SCP-323 don’t
stop there.
The skull has an inherent ability to influence
the minds of those around it.
Anyone spending an hour within a fifteen-meter
radius of SCP-323 is likely to experience
the effects of this influential power.
This will often result in them exhibiting
uncharacteristic behaviors, thoughts, and
urges, including cannibalistic tendencies
and outbursts of random violence.
Almost three quarters of people that suffer
the influence of SCP-323 will feel an overwhelming
compulsion to take the Wendigo’s Skull and
fit their heads into the chiseled hole on
its rear underside.
If someone attempting this finds that their
head is too big to fit inside the hollow skull,
there have been cases of individuals trying
to bludgeon their heads on any hard surface
they can find nearby in an attempt to get
their head down to a more manageable size.
This will continue until one of three outcomes
occurs: one, the person manages to fit their
head into the skull.
Two, they cause themselves so much cranial
damage that they are rendered unconscious.
Or three, they end up killing themselves through
repeated violent head trauma.
Of course, if a person actually manages to
fit their head inside SCP-323, then that is
a different story entirely.
In these instances, the individual becomes
classified as an instance of SCP-323-1.
Within ten minutes of wearing the skull, this
person will suffer dramatic changes to their
body.
Any and all body fat will be rapidly shed
as their hair also begins to fall out, leaving
them looking starved and almost skeletal in
appearance.
Their distal phalanges - those are the bones
at the tip of the fingers - will elongate
and rupture the skin as they become bony,
claw-like appendages.
The subject will also find that their teeth
have grown abnormally long and sharp, while
their limbs will blacken as if they were suffering
frostbite symptoms.
Along with their external transformations,
SCP-323-1 will also get increased strength
and a heightened resistance to pain.
They aren’t invulnerable though, and can
still sustain damage and injuries.
SCP-323-1 will also have a dramatic change
happen to their metabolism, which will occur
a few minutes into the physical transformation.
The subject will now need an almost constant
intake of calories, which if they don’t
receive, will cause them to starve almost
instantly.
With the transformation process complete,
the new instance of SCP-323-1 has finally
become the Wendigo.
A terrifying monster with one goal - to feed.
The SCP-323-1 instance will seek out any human
beings it can find so that it can feed upon
their flesh.
Those who have witnessed the 323-1 instance
in the midst of a feeding frenzy have described
the way it violently slaughtered any person
it could find, leaving only a mess of blood
as it devoured them, their screams mixed in
with the sounds of bones crunching.
In the times that the creature cannot find
a human to nourish its monstrous appetite,
it will try to keep itself alive anyway it
can.
Sometimes it will slow down its movement to
try and conserve energy, other times it will
ration whatever food is available to it, saving
some of its last meal for a leftover snack.
And on occasion, the monster will engage in
autocannibalism, a form of cannibalism that
involves eating parts of itself.
Humans certainly seem to be its preferred
food source though.
Even when other sources of meat would be easier
to acquire, SCP-323-1 will zero in on human
beings and do anything it can to make a person
its next meal.
When chasing down its prey, human or otherwise,
SCP-323-1 has been observed uttering phrases
either spoken in the primary language of whoever
was transformed by the skull, or in the Severn
Ojibwe, Potawatomi, and Cree languages.
These are all native languages of the numerous
indigenous cultures that shared legends of
the Wendigo.
Where do the phrases come from, though?
Are they another side effect of SCP-323’s
influence, or do they originate from the skull
itself?
The Foundation’s researchers are still trying
to figure that out, and at the moment have
no clues as to where they come from.
In one containment breach in 2006, during
which an instance of SCP-323-1 was able to
kill and devour twelve members of Foundation
personnel, on site surveillance recorded audio
of the creature speaking.
“Hungry… so hungry” it rasped, while
dragging a body behind it.
“I… must eat.
So very hungry.
Always… always hungry.”
After this, the sound of a wet cracking noise
was recorded, possibly one of the victim’s
bones being broken by SCP-323-1 so it could
get to the marrow inside.
The 323-1 instance does at times seem to try
and resist the influence of the wendigo skull.
Additional recordings captured the creature
saying “Must… not eat.
I have to eat.
So hungry.
So… lonely,” the creature then said, followed
by noises of it eating the body.
“Alone.
Hungry.
Should… eat.
Must.
Must… eat them all.
I must eat… to know… warmth.
So cold!
Must eat!”
It seems that even the wendigo has its own
internal struggles, perhaps showing that there
is still something left of the human who put
on the skull, and that deep down they are
fighting against their cannibalistic impulses.
But where exactly did the Foundation find
SCP-323?
And is it really the skull of an actual Wendigo,
the famous creature from North American legend?
In 1997, the SCP Foundation sent a detachment
to Bittern Lake in Saskatchewan, Canada.
There had been reports of a local community
murdering individuals and leaving their bodies
in the forest to appease a dangerous creature
residing nearby.
This creature, as it was later discovered,
was an instance of SCP-323-1.
Someone had found the skull and succumbed
to its influence, placing it on their head,
and turning into a monster.
Ever since, the locals had been killing people
and offering up their dead bodies as sustenance,
fearful of what would happen if they didn’t
after being brought up with legends of the
Wendigo.
SCP Foundation agents were able to capture
the beast, however it died of starvation while
being transported back to containment.
They also covered up the recent deaths in
the area by giving the local residents amnestics,
and creating a cover story about an unidentified
serial killer.
Prior to this, James Namagoose, a local man
who was involved in the murders was brought
in for questioning.
He remained oddly calm when interviewed, but
admitted he had helped move the bodies that
were being offered up as food for SCP-323-1,
or as he called it, the Wendigo.
According to James, a local story among the
Cree people told of men who had once tried
to control a Wendigo, and perhaps even tame
it through offerings of food.
Whether or not James and his fellow locals
had the same intention, their primary concern
was keeping themselves safe.
He described first encountering the creature:
“A warped man walked out of the woods, killed
our friends right in front of us.
Sometimes it would stare more than it would
make to kill, try to talk to you.
It whispered at me, ‘pe misto’, ‘come
and eat’.
It made me cold in my bones.”
As the interview continued, James claimed
he had felt like he understood this ‘warped
man’.
He described feeling like the Wendigo was
encouraging him to kill, that the creature
would help him pass when his own time came.
James told the Foundation doctor questioning
him that he had heard the creature in his
mind, and had felt it watching him almost
constantly.
Mr Namagoose stated that he’d hoped, in
killing people as offerings to the Wendigo,
that his own family would be spared.
Like the other locals, James Namagoose was
given amnestics to forget all about the creature
and the murders he’d played a part in committing.
So far, none of the Foundation’s staff have
experienced any similar behavioral effects
to those James described.
Those who work closely with SCP-323 or have
witnessed an instance of SCP-323-1, have felt
the creature communicating with them, or urging
them to kill on its behalf.
Ultimately, who’s to say if SCP-323 is the
skull of a Wendigo like those from the legends?
It certainly seems like it is, but with no
way to tell exactly how old the skull is,
perhaps it’s actually the reverse and it
was the Wendigo legend that spawned from instances
of SCP-323-1 that were first encountered by
indigenous North American cultures hundreds
of years ago.
One thing is for certain, if you ever come
across a skull with tall antlers, you should
try to resist putting it on.
Otherwise, you might not be feeling like yourself
for much longer.
Now go check out “SCP-3166 - Monster Garfield
Attack (Gorefield)” and “SCP-2317 - The
Devourer of Worlds / A Door to Another World”
for more monstrous SCPs that’ll haunt your
dreams!